that's interesting because I like the
idea of having multiple streams of
income because I'm terrified of not
having an income basically I think the
idea of relying on one centralized
individual or place or whatever just
terrifies me so is there a number a
month that you would say okay that's if
you're making that then you can have
multiple streams of income yeah so I
think for for me is how big is your
vision period because okay let's process
this guy Elan right PayPal what's he
sell it for they sell it for 1.5 billion
of the 1.5 billion they sold it for his
net was 180. of the 180 he got you know
which company he put the most money in
which one do you know this one I don't
is it it's pretty interesting because I
thought it's going to be the other one
out of the 180. he put a hundred million
into SpaceX 70 in Tesla and 10 he put
into the Solar Company or something no
now into the boring company or Solar
Company but the most money he put into
SpaceX 70 Tesla and the 10 goes
elsewhere right so the Solar Company
today if you look at the valuation I
want to say it's a 24 billion dollar
company I may be wrong 25 billion dollar
company give or take Tesla's valuation
one two trillion I think today it's at
around 680 700 billion dollars right the
solar thing or whatever else he's got
going on now he spends 50 well 44
billion to buy you know Twitter which I
believe he'll turn into a trillion
dollar company have my specific reasons
why I believe he can do that if you look
at that case study the difference
between a Bezos and a musk they both
want to go create you know go into space
and all that other stuff right who do
you think is doing it to add to their
resumes and who do you think is doing it
because they truly want to go find out
what the hell is going on in space Elon
Musk is doing it
because since he was a kid he read that
one book Galaxy you know so to him it's
like man I've always been enamored with
space Bezos was like nope I'm gonna get
there it's like a resume checklist like
Russell Brand you know what's his name
um uh uh uh the guy from Virgin uh uh
Richard Branson Richard Branson right so
he's kind of like I'm gonna go as well
but it's different reasons elon's not
going to space because he wants to say I
got there before you did he's truly
trying to figure out what's going on so
again multiple streams of income what's
your vision my vision was a completely
different Vision because my concern was
how people are controlling the narrative
by owning a lot of different media
platforms and so like Forbes do you know
Forbes uh was bought by a Chinese
company do you know Forbes that was
originally the founder Forbes his son
took it to the next level incredible
story what his son did but then uh the
next guy took it over uh whoever's
running it right now
Steve Forbes I want to say he eventually
sold it to a China company that owns 95
percent of Forbes today do you know who
they announced the international woman
of the year was last year in 2021 I
actually did a wonderful woman named
Hillary Clinton oh she's the woman can
you imagine Forbes where the guy who ran
Forbes the plane was called capitalists
tool that he would travel everywhere he
put a birthday party together on his
70th birthday party he invited everybody
he was best friends with Elizabeth
Taylor I think six 700 people showed up
to his birthday you know what he gave to
everybody on his birthday a Rolex watch
to every guest okay so this guy was like
the voice for capitalism who buys Forbes
95 of China so for me the vision of why
we're making money is to be able to
control the narrative we're capitalist
is still the hero so if you're going
back to your
you can't imagine having only one stream
of income it all depends on Division if
you're trying to build to sell to get a
lot of money then to have a lot of
different things well that's a different
Vision than somebody that's trying to
have it today
[Music]